mark Whalberg use the new Shia LaBeouf
exciting times
he's from Texas but he has a Boston
accent transformers age of extinction
okay so um when I first saw the
Transformers franchise all admit first
one I thought was very boring second one
fell asleep through most of it third one
yeah I think I saw like the first ten
minutes and then I was like now's a good
time to take a nap this one I was
actually paying attention the whole time
I I rather enjoyed it for the most part
just because I say that doesn't mean
it's a good movie it's pretty bad at
times there's some horrible things it's
pretty awful it's like having an STD
okay like for starters yes okay yeah the
action and visual effects it's [ __ ]
top-notch I saw some IMAX 3d some of the
3d was [ __ ] phenomenal it was like
really coming at you and like the
daughter in 3d was pretty [ __ ]
amazing I I really look at her I really
I want to come I want to [ __ ] her really
bad I'm gonna think about her tonight I
went with Murray to watch this movie and
it was a quite an exciting experience
there's a little boy who just kept
making a lot of noise next to her Murray
started yelling at this kid it was
intense
she uh she's like you little [ __ ]
brat it was whoa it was awesome though
it was awesome happy to be experienced
but yeah the action of visual effects
it's [ __ ] beautiful in this film some
of it it's a little too much at times
there's like a lot of it it's this is
like almost a three-hour film and it's
like non-stop action for a long period
of time they [ __ ] up China a lot in this
movie China got ass [ __ ] didn't this
film do but it's gonna do well in China
because it takes place in China but yeah
Mark Wahlberg um he was good he was
really cool I like him more than Shia
LaBeouf I appeal his characters more
relatable there was some writing about
him that I thought was a little bit
annoying like the first 90 minutes was
him pretty much just lecturing his
daughter and telling his daughter uh you
can't be with his boyfriend who just
saved her [ __ ] ass but still he's
like nope
ya can't be with him even though he's a
goddamn American Hero right now can't be
with him the daughter yes bangable but
honestly she's a pretty bad actress
kind of annoying like really annoying
like I would have sex with her but I'd
tape her mouth shut it would be
consensual though it's not what it
sounds like
stanley tucci he's great in this film
like I he's probably the best actor in
this whole movie he doesn't play a gay
guy again like you always plays him he's
really [ __ ] enjoyable I had a great
time watching this dude and this is the
first time we're actually gave a [ __ ]
about Optimus Prime I didn't I wasn't
like overly concerned or really cared a
lot but in this one you know it is kind
of cool seeing like this guy who feels a
little bit hurt and betrayed by humans
but he's still like conflicted it was
the first time where I was like we got
some Optimus Prime character in there
and the Dinobots Dinobots show up like
it's a three-hour film they show about
like 2 hours and 45 minutes into the
movie they were pretty cool though I'm
not gonna lie they're pretty [ __ ]
sweet and some of the plot stuff doesn't
really make sense there's a little bit
too many plots going on
you gotta like the bad guys the new bad
guys and then you got the CIA who's a
bad guy then you get like another
villain halfway through and then there's
more details amongst the CIA that it's
just there's a little too much going on
but this is the first Transformers phone
where I did not fall asleep I enjoyed it
for the most part even though I know
it's not one of the greatest movies of
all time the story still the story and
characters are still pretty cheesy and
lacked good development but overall if
you're going in there for some bomb
action some bomb visual effects and just
looking to have an entertaining time I
think it delivers for the most part
although if you fall asleep I'll
actually understand it's all really long
it's really long like some things
talking about my penis marine my penis
is long it's a long penis sure no it is
trust me do I see it I'll show you
which thing I'm trying to be nice to you
now you're ruining this let me get
straight to the point here all I got to
see transformers age of extinction got
it right for what it's supposed to be
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for transformers age of
extinction once you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell me would you
bang this girl Mark Wahlberg's daughter
not the real daughter I don't know I
don't throw out there you can follow me
on twitter and real rejects has a
Facebook and a vine now as well we got
all the social network stuff promotion
face anyone throughout there - did this
one of the review with Jeremy for
transformers where we goin t knows you
know if you if you don't care about
spoilers because honestly you won't ruin
the [ __ ] movie for you people like to
spoiler review and last but not least if
you want to get updated every time one
of my reviews or videos is outgoing and
clear on this but if I might dig to
subscribe that's right the dick let me
say something about this little optimism
right now he is in his prime and he can
transform any woman's
I don't know I was going good and then I
[ __ ] about I'm sorry